aquí tenemos la estructura de puntos del
mentol qué es un compuesto famoso
encontrado en diversos aceites de menta
nuestro objetivo es dibujar las dos con
formaciones de silla del mentol y luego
vamos a elegir la más estable lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es asignar números
a nuestros sustituyen test en el anillo
y la manera en la que se asignan números
no tiene que seguir la nomenclatura de
la iupac por ejemplo voy a llamar a este
carbono 1 este carbono 2 a este carbono
3 y carbono 4 si ya sabes cómo nombrar a
este compuesto entonces sabrás que no es
así como se asignan números a los
carbonos de acuerdo con la nomenclatura
iupac pero utilizaremos este sistema de
numeración para ayudarnos a dibujar
nuestras con formaciones de silla vamos
a empezar con una conformación de silla
ya hemos visto cómo dibujar con
formaciones de silla comenzamos con dos
líneas paralelas que están un poco
desfasada una con respecto a la otra
después trazamos una línea punteada que
apenas toca en la parte superior de la
línea de arriba y luego otra línea
punteada que va a ir aquí y tocar la
punta inferior de la línea de abajo
después pensamos en otro conjunto de
líneas paralelas trazamos una línea
partiendo de la línea de arriba hasta
aquí abajo y luego trazamos una paralela
a la línea que acabamos de dibujar y
finalmente dibujamos nuestra última
serie de líneas paralelas ya tenemos
nuestra estructura de carbono ahora
tenemos que colocar nuestros enlaces a
este carbono le asignamos el número uno
y sabemos que empezamos axial arriba en
el carbono 1 en el carbono 12 sexual
abajo y seguimos alternando en el
carbono 13 sachs ya la riva en el
carbono 4 es axial abajo en el carbono 5
es axial arriba y en el carbono 6 es
axial abajo
a continuación colocamos los enlaces
ecuatoriales así que en el carbono 1
sería ecuatorial abajo en el carbono 2
sería arriba en el carbono 3 iría abajo
en el carbono 4 va hacia arriba en el
carbono 5 hacia abajo y por último en el
carbono 6 sería hacia arriba echemos un
vistazo a los grupos en el anillo
tenemos un grupo metilo en el carbono 1
y puesto que tiene una cuña eso
significa que va hacia arriba en el
espacio por lo tanto vamos a poner el
grupo metilo hacia arriba con respecto
al plano del anillo así que eso
significa que el grupo metilo es axial
ya que el enlace axial es el único que
va hacia arriba en el carbono 1
a continuación nos fijamos en el h
el o h va hacia arriba en el carbono 3
pero primero vamos a numerar nuestros
carbonos este es el carbono 1 2
y 4 muy bien vamos a poner el h al
cierre y va en el carbono 3 y la única
manera en que podemos hacerlo es
poniendo el h axial vamos a poner el h
aquí en el carbono 3 y va hacia arriba
en el espacio y finalmente tenemos
nuestro grupo y su propio en el carbono
4 el cual está unido con guiones por lo
tanto se encuentra lejos de nosotros en
el espacio o hacia abajo con respecto al
plano del anillo así que tenemos dos
opciones donde ponemos a nuestro grupo
hizo pro pilot debe de ir hacia abajo en
relación al plano del anillo lo que
significa que es axial ya que ese es el
único enlace que va hacia abajo en el
carbono 4 vamos a dibujar a nuestro
grupo y sobre pilot en el carbono 4
así que esta es una conformación de
silla del mentol muy bien sabemos que
esta conformación de silla está en
equilibrio con nuestra otra conformación
de silla así que vamos a dibujarla
tenemos dos líneas paralelas desfasadas
entre sí y luego dibujamos nuestras
líneas punteadas sólo las utilizamos
como guías para que nos ayuden a dibujar
nuestra conformación de silla vamos
desde este punto hasta la línea de abajo
y de nuestra línea de abajo a nuestra
línea superior y conectamos los puntos
para obtener la conformación de silla
sabemos que este es el carbono 1 así que
empezamos axial abajo en el carbono 1 es
lo contrario de la otra conformación de
silla
este es el carbono 2 aquí va axial
arriba en el carbono 3 sería axial abajo
en el carbono 4 es axial arriba en el
carbono 5 es axial abajo
y en el carbono 6 da axial arriba ahora
vamos con los ecuatoriales en el carbono
esto sería arriba y luego en el carbono
2 sería hacia abajo
por lo tanto sólo seguimos alternando en
el carbono 3 va hacia arriba en el
carbono 4 abajo en el carbono 5 arriba y
en el carbono 6 abajo
sabemos que cuando ocurre una inversión
del anillo este es el carbono 1 este es
el carbono 2
este es el carbono 3 y este es el
carbono 4
ahora vamos a colocar nuestros grupos
sabemos que en el carbono 1 tenemos un
grupo metilo y este grupo metilo va
hacia arriba con respecto al plano del
anillo
sabemos que cuando ocurre una inversión
del anillo el grupo metilo tiene que
mantenerse arriba así que el grupo
metilo pasa de estar axial arriba a
ecuatorial arriba cuando ocurre una
inversión del anillo ahora vamos a ver o
h
el o h también está arriba con respecto
al plano del anillo va a ir en el
carbono 3 y va a estar arriba con
respecto al plano del anillo se
encuentra axial arriba en la
conformación de silla de la izquierda y
por lo tanto va ecuatorial arriba en la
conformación de silla de la derecha y
por último nos fijamos en el carbono 4
tenemos nuestro grupo isopropílico que
se encuentra hacia abajo con respecto al
plano del anillo por lo que va a
permanecer abajo pero va a pasar de ser
axial a ser ecuatorial aquí está nuestro
grupo isopropílico que va hacia abajo
con respecto al plano del anillo a veces
es muy difícil saber si un enlace
ecuatorial va hacia arriba o hacia abajo
con respecto al plano
para de saberlo es mirar al enlace axial
en el mismo carbono este enlace axial en
el carbono 4 aquí va hacia arriba por lo
que este enlace ecuatorial va hacia
abajo este es un pequeño truco para
ayudarte si tienes problemas con estos
enlaces muy bien ahora apoya dibujar a
los hidrógenos ya que dibuje todos estos
enlaces voy a dibujar también los
hidrógenos en estas con formaciones de
silla voy a dejar fuera los hidrógenos
del grupo y sobre pilot no tienes que
poner todos estos hidrógenos cuando
estás dibujando tus con formaciones de
silla en realidad probablemente es más
fácil entender la estructura sino los
dibujas pero si esto te ayuda a
comprender mejor las conformaciones de
si ya puedes hacerlo así que ahora
tenemos las dos con formaciones de silla
y vamos a analizarlas en términos de
estabilidad
pero primero vamos a ver un vídeo para
asegurarnos de que dibujamos las
conformaciones de silla adecuadamente
aquí tenemos una conformación de silla
para el mentón en el carbono 1 hay un
grupo metilo axial arriba si esto es el
carbono 1 el carbono 2 en el carbono 3
tenemos 1 h axial arriba en el carbono 4
hay un grupo y su propio axial abajo si
ocurre una inversión del anillo si roto
este carbono hacia arriba y luego roto
este carbono hacia abajo y lo giramos un
poco para ver la conformación de silla
mejor puedes ver que todos estos grupos
de los que hablamos pasaron de ser
axiales a ser ecuatoriales que es el
lugar más estable para estos
relativamente voluminosos sustituye
entes vamos a comparar las
conformaciones de sí ya que dibujamos
con lo que vimos en el vídeo en el vídeo
este es el carbono 1 y se puede ver que
este grupo metilo está axial arriba y
eso es lo que tenemos aquí nuestro grupo
metilo está axial arriba
este es el carbono 2
este es el carbono 3 y aquí tenemos
nuestro
axial arriba y aquí también está axial
arriba luego en el carbono 4 deberíamos
tener un grupo y sobre pilot que va
hacia abajo en el espacio
este es el carbono 4 no se puede ver el
enlace pero se puede ver que este grupo
y su propio va hacia abajo cuando a esta
conformación de silla le ocurre una
inversión del anillo todos estos enlaces
axiales se vuelven ecuatoriales podemos
verlo aquí en el lado derecho este sería
el carbono 1 ahora y el grupo metilo
está todavía arriba en relación con el
plano del anillo pero es ecuatorial y el
hidrógeno que estaba ecuatorial aquí
ahora se encuentra axial justo como lo
tenemos aquí
este es el carbono 2 este es el carbono
3 en el carbono 3 tenemos nuestro h
ecuatorial arriba igual que como lo
dibujamos aquí y luego en el carbono 4
tenemos nuestro grupo isopropílico
ecuatorial abajo aquí está también abajo
sabemos que la posición ecuatorial es la
posición más estable para sustituye
entes relativamente voluminosos por lo
tanto si los tres sustituyen t se
encuentran ecuatoriales entonces esta es
la conformación más estable en este caso
es fácil saber cuál es la conformación
de silla más estable a veces es un poco
más difícil y puede que necesites
consultar a una tabla y ver cuáles son
las diferencias en energía entre las dos
posiciones